[Music]
fans of Oprah will see her famous
clothes and a whole lot more at a new
exhibit in Toronto an American culture I
love it there's that red dress from her
famous car giveaway the exhibit also has
her iconic talk show set complete with
audience chairs
check out the tissues under the seats
CBS this morning captured Oprah and
Gayle King's first look at the treasure
trove of historical artifacts wow this
is amazing yeah they were guided by
museum director Lonnie bunch well there
aren't many things that can withstand
the test of time and this is what I was
doing my own hair the Smithsonian's
National Museum of african-american
history and culture has put together an
amazing display that showcases Oprah's
influence on American culture
I do believe that we had a big impact on
the culture and I continue to feel that
from people every day
and welcome to the very first national
opera shop I was so nervous that day I
had hives under my armpits seeing how
her impact has changed the world truly
overwhelmed her that makes me want to
cry
this was your gift and our gift to
America and so we want to thank you for
that for doing just night it means a lot
to us thank you you're the best thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]